gordon mcgill is a trucker with over 25
years of experience he recently penned
an op-ed for newsweek titled elites are
smearing truckers because we're doing
their job representing the people i
loved that op-ed we're happy that gord
is with us tonight who joins us um your
reaction
to this freakout gourd
among the elites in canada and the media
and the politically powerful here
well thank you for having me on laura
yeah it's been very uh
illuminating to see how poorly
me and my fellow road warriors have been
treated in the media um they attempted
to smear us with a couple of guys with
flags uh two saturdays ago in ottawa uh
two guys out of a hundred thousand
people on the capitol and they're using
this to basically say we're all these
fringe right-wing extremists even though
there's people at the protests from all
walks of life people at the protests who
aren't even truckers
the truckers have set up a community
kitchen in downtown ottawa ravers have
showed up in the evenings and set up
sound systems on the weekends and people
have come and danced because they're so
joyous because they want their freedom
back and it's a celebration yet
the media would have you believe that
we're basically nazis and it's
ridiculous and so i had to say something
about it
anyone
who's not in agreement with the elites
on all these issues whether it's trade
or whether it's coveted mandates if if
dissenters get together and actually
enjoy themselves at a protest peacefully
that's a bigger threat to the elites
than anything china will ever do so
that's what i said the fear that they
talk about it's their fear fear of
losing power and speaking of this gord
this so-called populist premier you guys
have in ontario doug ford
he's announcing this massive crackdown
on all of you truckers watch
today i'm using my authority as premier
of ontario to declare a state of
emergency in our province
and i will convene cabinet to use legal
authorities to urgently enact orders
that will make crystal clear
it is illegal and punishable
to block
and impede
the movement of goods
people
and services along critical
infrastructure we cannot
we and i emphasize cannot have people
occupying cities
holding them hostage
i don't remember any of those people
talking about the cities being occupied
in the united states by violent
protesters and the summer of love uh
gord but are you guys going to start
going to jail getting put in jail
well it remains to be seen how the
police react to this but the the
premier's choice of language is very
indicative like he's considering ottawa
under siege and i think that belies the
fact that they do see that we have
incredible leverage the ambassador
bridge has been slowed down for the last
four days the blue water bridge has been
slowed down for the last four days
automotive plants are running out of
parts all across the economy we're
affecting it and that is what they're
afraid of they're afraid of a legitimate
spontaneously organized
workers uprising that has more power
than they do
and why don't they just drop the
mandates
that would say good question
that that is a good question and i i
note that none of the
i watched that enter i watched that
presser with premier ford and none of
the media people who were there asked
premier ford whether he or prime
minister trudeau had spoken with any of
the organizers of the convoy
nobody has talked to us yet like
where's the discussion where's the
negotiations
now you're illegitimate and they think
you're terrorists that's end of story
they're not going to talk to you gord
thank you for appearing tonight we
really really appreciate it and best of
luck out there hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else